lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
brindar una visión general de lo que es
la respiración celular la cual puede ser
un proceso bastante bastante complejo
incluso digamos lo que lo que mostraré a
continuación ya es bastante complicado
ya que iremos por ejemplo desde la
molécula de glucosa veremos cómo se
producen digamos atp durante la
glucólisis y también veremos por ejemplo
el ciclo de krebs también veremos un
poco de la fosforilación oxidativa pero
en realidad todas digamos
todas estas moléculas pueden pueden
estar saltando a distintas partes de la
cadena y seguir otro tipo de rutas
verdad aquí yo simplemente mostraré lo
que sería digamos la la versión
tradicional de lo que es la respiración
celular así que empecemos con la glucosa
verdad podemos ver esta cadena de 6
carbonos verdad tenemos una cadena de 6
carbonos y tenemos el proceso de la
glucólisis verdad que ocurre en el sito
sol de las células así que vamos a
escribir eso la glucólisis ocurre
justamente en el sito sol muy bien así
que por ejemplo si nos vamos a la célula
que tenemos por ejemplo de este lado
aquí tenemos nuestra célula
entonces la glucólisis ocurre justamente
en el sito sol verdad aquí es en donde
ocurre la glucólisis y esto lo pongo así
para que veamos realmente dónde es que
se lleva a cabo a cabo verdad entonces
en realidad la glucólisis verdad si
regresamos digamos a esta parte inicial
la glucólisis consiste en romper la
molécula de glucosa en dos moléculas de
tres átomos de carbono cada cada una de
ellas verdad y estas moléculas tienen un
nombre muy particular y se les conoce
como piruvato muy bien los piru batos
son estas dos moléculas que tienen tres
átomos de carbono y ahora bien la
glucólisis digamos una de las
características más importantes es que
produce dos moléculas de
verdad dos moléculas netas verdad en
realidad porque produce cuatro moléculas
de atp pero requiere 22 moléculas de atp
para llevarse a cabo entonces por cada
digamos moléculas de glucosa tendremos
dos moléculas de atp muy bien así que
vamos a ir digamos llevando la cuenta en
esta tabla que he pintado aquí verdad
para que digamos tengamos una mejor
noción de qué es lo que va ocurriendo a
lo largo de la respiración celular
entonces aquí en la glucólisis vamos a
poner que hay 2 atp es que se producen y
es una producción neta verdad en este
proceso también estamos reduciendo dos
moléculas de nada más aunque íbamos a
llamarlo sido 2n ade-más muy bien lo
vamos a reducir en dos moléculas de nh
verdad así que recordemos que la
reducción verdad es la ganancia de
electrones así que en realidad estamos
yendo de una molécula que tiene una
carga positiva a una carga neutral así
que estamos gana
y electrones verdad entonces este
proceso que tenemos aquí de hecho lo voy
a poner más arriba este proceso que
tenemos aquí es una reacción de
reducción reducción porque estamos
ganando electrones verdad entonces vamos
a agregar también a nuestra tabla que
estamos consiguiendo dos moléculas de nh
vamos a poner aquí dos moléculas de n
de h muy bien ahora bien hay una especie
de digamos de decisión digamos si
suponemos que no hay mucho oxígeno
alrededor verdad o digamos estamos
hablando de de algún organismo que no
puede hacer digamos la respiración
celular por alguna razón entonces el
piruvato se puede utilizar para la
fermentación que puede ser una
fermentación láctica o puede ser
fermentación alcohólica y el punto de la
fermentación es usar los piruvato es
verdad para oxidar nh de vuelta
n además muy bien entonces lo que está
ocurriendo con la fermentación es que
vamos a oxidar nh de vuelta a enea de
más muy bien para poder utilizarse
nuevamente en el proceso de la
glucólisis por otro lado digamos si
suponemos que no nos vamos por la ruta
de la fermentación y por ejemplo
seguimos con la respiración celular
aeróbica verdad es decir cuando cuando
hay presencia de oxígeno entonces lo
próximo que va a ocurrir es que para
cada uno de estas para cada una de estas
moléculas de piruvato lo que ocurre es
que este grupo car box y lo que tenemos
por aquí
este grupo car box y lo que se separan
del piruvato y esencialmente se libera
como dióxido de carbono entonces este
grupo car box y lo aquí es lo que aquí
digamos ya se ha convertido en dióxido
de carbono muy bien entonces se libera
el dióxido de carbono y digamos el resto
del piruvato verdad que que en esencia
es un grupo
estilo se une a la coenzima y muy bien
esta es la coenzima ha y solo para que
quede más claro este sería nuestro
nuestro grupo acetil o verdad que es lo
que quedó del piruvato cuando removimos
digamos este grupo car box y lo y ese
mismo grupo es este que tenemos aquí
verdad que está unido a nuestra coenzima
verdad y aquí de hecho tenemos un átomo
de azufre que es lo que está uniendo a
la coenzima y al grupo acetil o muy bien
de hecho algo importante que hay que
mencionar de la coenzima es que en
realidad es una molécula muy compleja de
hecho aquí tengo una imagen de lo que
ocurre una vez que ya hemos digamos
digamos unido el acetil con la cuenta y
mapa de verdad esta es una imagen de que
de qué es lo que ocurre verdad y podemos
ver que en realidad es una molécula muy
compleja verdad de hecho por aquí nada
más esta parte es nuestra cuenta
el perdón es nuestro grupo acetil y en
realidad el resto de esta molécula es
una coenzima verdad
el que juega es transferir esencialmente
este grupo hace ti lo verdad y somos
bastante observadores podemos ver aquí
algunas cosas muy importantes por
ejemplo esto que tenemos aquí es una
adenina verdad aquí por ejemplo tenemos
una ribosa verdad acá tenemos dos grupos
fosfato verdad y si uno digamos tiene ya
mucha habilidad distinguiendo este tipo
de estructuras biológicas puede darse
cuenta que en esencia lo que tenemos en
el extremo es a bp todo todo lo que
hemos hablado digamos hasta este momento
ha sido facilitado por enzimas verdad
las cuales tienen sus propias con
enzimas y una vez que tenemos digamos
esta unión esta unión del acetil con la
verdad podemos entonces entrar al ciclo
del ácido cítrico pero antes de
adentrarnos en el ciclo del ácido
cítrico vamos a seguir el conteo de lo
que hemos producido verdad en este
proceso de separar el grupo car box y lo
verdad del del piruvato también se
reduce
una molécula de n además muy bien se
reduce por supuesto en nh y eso pasa por
cada uno de estos pilotos que teníamos
aquí verdad pero digamos de la molécula
inicial de glucosa obtuvimos 22 piru
gatos así que en realidad aquí todo esto
hay que multiplicarlo por 2 verdad y así
vamos a estar multiplicando por 2 en
varias ocasiones debido a que tenemos la
producción de dos moléculas de piruvato
verdad entonces en este proceso de ir de
piruvato acetil coa vamos a tener una
producción de 2 n a de h
muy bien eso es digamos nuestra
producción neta en este proceso verdad
ahora sí vamos a adentrarnos en lo que
es el ciclo de krebs vamos a ir más
abajo
por supuesto ustedes dirán bueno que es
el ciclo de crepes ya lo había
mencionado es el ciclo de el ácido
cítrico verdad eso es exactamente lo
mismo y es en donde se va a producir la
mayor cantidad de atp es verdad ya este
ciclo se le conoce de esta forma como el
ciclo del ácido cítrico porque vamos a
transferir el grupo acetil lo que
teníamos acá arriba
este grupo acetil o verdad que está
unido con la coenzima verdad
una vez que entra digámoslo a lo que
sería el ciclo de krebs verdad se va a
unir con el ácido oxálico muy bien y lo
que va a ocurrir es que estos dos átomos
de carbono se van a unir a estos cuatro
átomos de carbono que ya estaban en el
ácido entonces por ejemplo aquí estaba
uno dos tres cuatro y al unirse esos
átomos de carbono vamos a producir ácido
cítrico que ya tiene seis átomos de
carbono verdad es 1 2 3 4 5 y este de en
medio son 6 átomos de carbono muy bien
entonces el ácido cítrico que es la
molécula que tenemos aquí es la molécula
que tienen los limones y las naranjas
que utilizamos digamos no sé cuando
comemos cosas de ese estilo verdad
entonces esta de aquí esta molécula de
aquí es el ácido cítrico y en general el
ciclo de krebs es bastante complicado
pero voy a tratar de dar un panorama de
qué es lo que ocurre en el entonces el
ciclo de krebs o el ciclo del del ácido
cítrico verdad digamos aquí ocurre que
el ácido
se va a romper en una serie de pasos
verdad cuyo cuyo detalle no estoy
mostrando aquí verdad pero al final al
final del ciclo regresa a ser nuevamente
ácido oxálico y puede aceptar nuevamente
carbono es verdad de el digamos del
grupo acetil lo que teníamos acá arriba
y repetir el ciclo de crepes así que
aquí vale la pena mencionar que una vez
que se ha tomado el grupo acetil o
verdad entonces nos quedan nuevamente la
coenzima a y esta coenzima puede usarse
nuevamente para descarbonizar piruvato
es verdad que era lo que teníamos en
este proceso entonces esta coenzima
puede regresar a descarboxilasa el
piruvato verdad ahora bien algo
importante que hay que mencionar es que
a medida que pasamos por las distintas
etapas del ciclo de krebs a medida que
pasamos por las distintas etapas de este
ciclo se van a estar reduciendo tiene
además en nh verdad y esto ocurre tres
veces a lo largo del
ciclo de krebs muy bien ocurre tres
veces por cada ciclo pero recordemos que
esto pasa por cada acetil co a verdad y
cada uno de estos digamos en realidad
tenemos dos verdad porque teníamos dos
piruvato originales entonces si todo
esto ocurre por cada una de estas
moléculas por cada grupo acetil o que
venía en la coenzima a entonces en
realidad vamos a tener seis moléculas de
nh al final verdad son tres veces por el
ciclo de krebs y esto ocurre dos veces
por cada uno de los pilotos que teníamos
así que aquí tenemos seis vamos a
escribirlo en nuestra tabla en el ciclo
de krebs tenemos la producción de seis
moléculas de enea de h muy bien ahora
también al recorrer el ciclo podemos ver
algo muy particular verdad en realidad
podemos ver que se produce dióxido de
carbono y además vamos a tener una
molécula llamada gp que está gp se puede
convertir en gtp oa veces también
podemos tener
y pasa a convertirse en atp aunque son
funcionalmente equivalentes así que para
simplificar todo esto vamos a poner en
la tabla que vamos a producir dos
moléculas de atp tú dirás porque dos si
sólo tenemos uno de estos pasos en el
ciclo bueno otra vez recordemos que eso
pasa por cada digamos grupo acetil o que
entra al ciclo de krebs y recordemos que
teníamos dos de estos verdad entonces
tenemos la producción de 2 atp es verdad
de esta parte ahora bien
aquí tenemos otra coenzima otra coenzima
que es fea de verdad fat que esta
coenzima se va a reducir en fadh 2 muy
bien y esto se mantiene unido digamos a
las enzimas que el que están facilitando
este proceso verdad y eso se usa para
reducir la coenzima q
h 2 muy bien así obtenemos dos moléculas
de q h 2 verdad otra vez recordemos
porque teníamos dos grupos hace tilos
entonces aquí vamos a poner dos q h dos
muy bien ahora vamos a pensar ahora si
en el producto neto de todo este de todo
este proceso verdad y vamos a utilizar
la información que detallaremos en otros
vídeos posteriores y hay que considerar
que tanto nada h verdad n a dh como
coche 2 se van a oxidar verdad se van a
oxidar en la fosforilación oxidativa y
en la cadena de transporte de electrones
que también veremos en un vídeo
posterior verdad entonces qué es lo que
ocurre cuando se oxidan en realidad
ocurre que van a crear un gradiente de
protones a través de la membrana interna
de la mitocondria y ese gradiente de
protones se utilizará para producir más
atp y una forma digamos resumida de
pensarlo es desde la forma siguiente
tenemos
tenemos que cada uno de estos enea de h
al final va a producir una cantidad de
atp es que son aproximadamente de 2 a 3
atp es muy bien de 2 a 3 atp es esto por
supuesto depende de la eficiencia de la
célula de la que estemos hablando ahora
bien si nos fijamos en q2 en q h 2 esto
al final del día digamos va a producir
entre 1.5 y 2 atp es muy bien entonces
la coenzima q digamos vamos vamos a
hacer la cuenta de vamos a hacer toda la
cuenta digamos de atp s atp es digamos
el solitos que hemos producido son 2
aquí y tenemos 2 acá en realidad tenemos
4 atp es verdad tenemos 4 atp muy bien
ahora de los nh tenemos 2 4 y 6 son
10 enea de h muy bien y también de coche
2 tenemos 2 verdad entonces tenemos 2 4
2 muy bien y si consideramos esta
conversión que va a haber al final del
día entonces tenemos que de estos 10 n a
de h
vamos a tener entre digamos si son 10
por 2 vamos a tener entre 20 y 10 por 3
que son 30 atp es muy bien de estos dos
coches 2 que tenemos bueno pues si
multiplicamos a 2 por 1.5 vamos a tener
entre 3 y 2 por 2 que son 4 atp muy bien
así que si sumamos tenemos 20 20 atp es
de esta parte 3 atp es de esta parte y 4
de esta parte digamos eso sería como el
mínimo número de atp es que podríamos
producir que son 27 atp es verdad 20 más
4 son 24 y 3 son 27 y el máximo que
podríamos alcanzar son 4 aquí
acá son 34 y 4 más son 38 atp esto sería
el máximo número teórico de atp es que
podríamos encontrar pero cuando digamos
los biólogos se ponen a contar digamos
en el laboratorio en realidad encuentran
que hay una producción aproximada de
entre 29 y 30 atp es de hecho por eso es
que este número 38 verdad se le
considera que es como el máximo teórico
verdad cuando observamos realmente qué
ocurre en la célula parece que se
producen 20 entre 29 y 30 atp nuevamente
todo depende de lo que esté tratando de
hacer la célula del tipo de célula que
esté realizando estos procesos y de los
niveles de eficiencia involucrados y
todo esto ocurre por la respiración
celular así que para tener un poco de
idea de qué es lo que está ocurriendo o
más bien dónde es que está ocurriendo ya
vimos que la glucólisis se lleva a cabo
en el sito sol de la célula pero si nos
fijamos en digamos ahora lo que es el
ciclo de krebs el ciclo de krebs
ocurre en lo que es la matriz de las
mitocondrias entonces aquí tenemos la
matriz de las mitocondrias
muy bien esta es la matriz y puedes
revisar el vídeo en khan academy que
hicimos particularmente para hablar de
la mitocondria verdad y lo que es la
cadena de transporte de electrones que
dijimos veremos en vídeos más digamos
posteriores está este digamos esta
cadena ocurre en la membrana de las
crestas verdad que son este tipo de
dobleces entonces aquí es en donde
ocurre la cadena de transporte de
electrones pero bueno todo esto todos
estos detalles digamos vamos a vamos a
entrar en más detalle de todos estos
procesos en próximos vídeos